some kind of sweet news around our
office one of our writers who's been
with us for a long time very talented
gentleman named Jose Arroyo had a
cartoon printed in The New Yorker he's a
talented artist and he had
[Applause]
it's a it's a huge honor and I'm sure
you'd all like to see the cartoon that
Hosea bro so what I'm gonna do now is
I'm gonna put up the card no no no no
wait wait wait wait no spoilers pls no
spoilers don't put it up yeah what's
what's wrong with you I'm not caught up
on my issues of The New Yorker I
subscribed a while ago cuz you know it's
a thing that smart people do and I want
to seem smart but they come every week
it's so hard to keep up so you know I'm
a little behind well how far behind are
you well I haven't read one since May
8th 1989 witness you on us to wait to
show Jose's cartoon to the audience
while you catch up on 30 years worth of
New Yorker magazines that's what you
want us to do would you oh that would be
so great thanks May 8 1989 here we go
more shouts less murmurs dance review
thank you listen thank you so much for
waiting I know that took way longer than
it should have all right well that's
fine Annie let's put Jose's cartoon up
on the screen let's show it there it is
look at that all the good ones are taken
huh I I don't get it neither did I
[Laughter]
[Applause]